I'm a mess of sports fan and football  and being a tener squash their two great  sports which I've never really mastered  golf I think it's partly because a  particular time I think what happens to  me or David Cameron Miliband is so much  less important than what's gonna happen  to the country like a sauna steam  connections David's time surely the  party that has got its nose in front of  the others either hasn't got an outright  majority has the right to try and  assembler government I hope David  doesn't mind that we will watch the  Labour Party has been a case study in  double standard 1 plus T nip them yellow  lorry lorry of course is more money in  your pocket their trees nature you know  you do this yourself no but it's benign  justification they're pointing because  they don't want ed Miliband and David  Cameron to cut their money go to their  school I apologize motivators and  cynical sisters off cracking socks can I  do a selfie with his sock